bonjour à tous lundi 16 mai je
n'imaginais pas aimer autant un jour
cette date je suis vraiment vraiment
ravi de vous retrouver et tout de suite
eh bien on reprend donc nos bonnes
habitudes comme si on ne s'était jamais
quitté avec les prévisions météo bonjour
et bienvenue à la maison des maternelles
à votre service on est en direct 9h50
bouger 10,50 sexe
il est huit mois mais voyant d'otages
est surtout pas
comme chez toi tu vois que ça avec la
caméra de call of
[Musique]
prypiat à merci saliha break ia et et
marc fauvelle pardon n'avait pas vu
qu'on était de retour à l'antenne il est
quasiment à 9 heures sur france info le
premier quinquennat d' emmanuel macron a
expiré vendredi à minuit mais le nouveau
premier ministre a toujours pas été
nommé toujours pas et jean castex n'a
toujours pas donné sa démission ce qui
devrait arriver dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochaines minutes nous
dit on en tout cas il est prêt à
repartir dans ces pyrénées pour
s'occuper de ses volets qui donne mérite
un petit coup de peinture voilà ce qu'il
a confié dans une interview donnée au
parisien
une bise et une accolade chaleureuse
entre jean castex premier ministre
démissionnaire et son ancien ministre du
travail et les avait bornes qui vient
prendre ses nouvelles fonctions sur le
perron de matignon elle est désormais la
deuxième femme première ministre de la
vème république
trente et un ans après edith cresson et
plus surprenant qu'on a vraiment investi
y est on a recherché les visas bêtement
on est également bien connue des
espagnols car oui notre première
ministre à une homonyme
qui chante
en espagne
mais ça me
[Musique]
mourir que ni bfm i lci ni france info
n'avait l'info car c'est aussi ça la bc
un magnéto que quand tu y parviens et
une info quand elle est bonne j'ai
confiance chez elisabeth d'abord permets
moi de te le dire en trois temps je te
connais je te vois agir tu étais au
gouvernement avant que je n'en devienne
le chef mais depuis juillet 2020 et
elisabeth borgne a ensuite remercié son
prédécesseur
maîtrisera pour le système accéder au
pouvoir suprême s'installer à la presse
ou vente et un à faire bander la france
elle est très bas
[Musique]
madonna elle n'a pas manqué
d'imagination pour apporter son soutien
à trois associations pour les femmes la
star américaine a révélé est mis en
vente trois vidéos en 3d des nfc réalisé
avec l'artiste numérique beatles un
triptyque modestement intitulé maire de
la création pour le moins imagé une mise
en scène osée mais parfaitement assumé
par la star et son double digital met
les oreilles sont à mogi les oreilles ne
serait pas vos vive donnant donnant rien
debout ce stade là qu est légèrement
spaceship si vous
voyez ici le grand foyer tour de cette
cheminée cette grande table en bois où
justement le maître queux va pouvoir
faire toutes sortes de préparations
alors maître queux et bien c'est celui
qui a la maîtrise justement de là que
l'on va poser ici là et bien cette poêle
ou cette casserole avec cette grande que
pour ne pas se brûler on a donc la
métrite celles ci on devient alors
mettre tout on a une toute petite tape
d'un coup ça fait tout drôle moi je suis
déstabiliser mais une belle aspergeant
[Rires]